[Music]
inaudible defeat news submitted by Irene
from Chicago I love you Chicago you got
bomb has pizza and hot dogs I don't know
how to do honorable defeats what is that
I just don't know how to lose I never
lose like I think being ok with oh I'm
Way ok with that [ __ ] dude I'm not
I've been loses his day one awesome a
Japanese man called the cops on himself
after not having enough money to pay for
his meal
what a loser that's as Japanese as it
gets most honorable [ __ ] he was
like call the police or kill myself I
just make sure putting his arm behind
his own bag of Japan cuz if it did it
Povey different I'm pretty sure happen
in Japan oh yeah it did they're more
civil out there so the cops came in the
Mario go kart carts and then they pulled
the ha ha ha you know they have tours
yeah I wanted to do it they're trying to
get rid of it or something cuz it's like
the pedestrians hated or some [ __ ] I
don't know or like the drivers I would
believe it anyway this guy so an
unemployed Japanese elderly man well
that's sad 63 year old senior he ended
up calling the class on himself after
not having enough money right so he goes
to his restaurant he orders a bowl of
cuts udon good but he only had 96 yen on
him which is about 86 cents and so after
he finished his meal that was worth 650
yen which is about 5 dollars and 75
cents that's becchi yeah he ended up
finishing the meal and he told the
restaurants manager to call the police
but the manager was lenient and he was
like it's cool don't worry about it just
come back and do my say sorta cuz he
ended up going to a nearby payphone
and he called the police he went out of
his way what the [ __ ] yeah I know what
he's doing
since he has he wants to go to jail to
be taken care of that's wrong getting it
well the police eventually arrested him
on suspicion of fraud and apparently
this was good that come from I know
that's why I said it's so weird I'm like
guys I'm hungry I need to go to jail
goes well what can we get him for mmm
well we maybe we could get him for fraud
okay okay come on I know I bet you guys
yeah cuz this wasn't the first time that
the senior has been to jail oh he
explained to the authorities that he was
hungry but he just didn't have enough
money to pay for his meal but yeah it's
pretty sad because they're saying that
about 20% of crime in japan is committed
by elderly people that's a lot yeah
because they kind of like nursing care
because they get fed three times a day
they have a roof over their head like
they get health check-ups so and there's
a social life yeah I get to hang out
with their buds do Japanese gentle must
be dope then dude I saw a documentary on
it the food looks good mmm but life
seems pretty [ __ ] hard okay never
mind okay cuz it's like the military
like you have to do everything [ __ ]
perfectly and you're just like it's not
like here where they just expect you to
just just live do what you want to do
yeah yeah everything is a regimen but
maybe it's different cuz the one I
watched was for hardcore criminals and
like death row people and then you know
how I was talking about how they don't
tell you when your date is you just wake
up every day thinking oh - today I might
die I wonder if he like kicked his own
ass later for being a [ __ ] snitch
like what the [ __ ] this was so honorable
dude I know it's so crazy you thought
all Taylor Beach like he just really
needed something that's pretty sad but
yeah there's this other elderly man that
was making the news because he turned
out to be a notorious ninja thief wait
wait wet a ninja people you know we're
talking about how seniors commit crimes
yeah so there's this other man there's
seventy four year olds they found out
that he was responsible for over two
hundred and fifty break-ins in the
more than eight years whether he was
dressed in all black like super like
ninja style but they finally caught him
cuz one when he was robbing a shop
he ended up lowering his mask so then it
eventually led to his arrest but the
authorities were so shocked because they
thought that all these break-ins were
done by someone young and agile so it's
kind of crazy that 74 years shitty is
their security this 74 year old man
robbed him uh you saw we could have
easily robbed someone we were caught so
we were in Japan we had just arrived we
had an Airbnb we were kind of lost where
Airbnb was there's like 12 people and
then we're all walking up this house of
this of these stairs inside this random
house that we thought was our Airbnb the
door was not locked and we just walked
in and we're like [ __ ] does not our
house go upstairs
then I see the TV flashing in the family
and I'm like oh it was like 20 people in
that house and they never suspect you
that there was that what if they heard
it and they got scared and they ran into
the room and they're [ __ ] hiding in
the closet oh maybe you got to Japan
feels so safe I felt like they were just
probably like that would have been funny
it was a really big house for us to
offer than that you know what I found
also hilarious every time I see you at
Ninja expert on YouTube it's a fat white
guy look I've been a ninja for 20 years
and I'm like are you fetid why are you
white do this ninjutsu school what I saw
this on YouTube but I think it's in
Germany or whatever he was like a
certified ninja and it's like this one
guy and then I saw this show it's like a
Japanese showed like clowning on him
like they're like what is [ __ ] ninja
[ __ ] there's subtitles it's pretty funny
it's so interesting you're like aha
where's the Japanese guy teaching this
like I'm wandering and he's like they're
like it's supposed to be the grand
master ninja but it's just there's like
this like white guy that you would see
masturbating to enemy porn Oh does it
mean ng think of us someone that's gonna
tiptoe across the roof but like 250
pounds are they just gonna fall through
the ceiling remember that movie with
Chris Farley the four kids of Beverly
Hills ninja Beverly Hills ninja
god dude here's basically what it is
dude that's all them dude is there like
a picture of the old man or anything
like that no there's just this really
bad blurry but did he really dress like
a ninja though yeah he was wearing all
black the whole mess and everything
they're even saying that was he moving
slow like he's 70 so even though he's
wearing all black he's still like like
that I don't know Dan that would be
crazy if they form like a like a street
gang of all seniors never suspect just
like in wheelchairs and [ __ ] and with
the eye patch and a [ __ ] Canyon they
said that happen to you in China yeah it
did happen to me but they weren't it was
a village oh okay but it was guys that
looked like our parents so like in their
50s and above yeah it but it was normal
people because I think down and out and
being hungry you you know you get pushed
doing some weird [ __ ]
no but this 74 year old ninja though
they're saying that when he was arrested
that he was telling the officers and
like he maintained his his ninja persona
because he was telling the officers like
I am defeated I thought I would never
get caught
oh wow even old people do role-playing
over there deafening the whole time and
[ __ ] there's a long-ass sound of you
breaking in and just I want to see the
Japanese grandpa thugs like I want to
see them like wearing hip-hop clothes
and [ __ ] and like the [ __ ] is beanie
itself like selling crack and [ __ ]
[ __ ] do you think you guys would be
that kind of elderly person where it's
like you still want to stay young so you
don't address I don't think I even
dressed young right now I thought it
like the other day like I really like
being older like it's I don't ever want
to be like they're like won't you want
to be 50 he'll [ __ ] no I'm not trying
to be 15 again dude I like this age that
I'm at right now
I only like getting older at this point
I would do it to [ __ ] with my grandkids
Oh baggy pants backwards like crisscross
if I only had grandkids I would wear
their clothes or like I would try to
find [ __ ] so then I could pass the [ __ ]
I don't yeah I would do it for that
perfect that dad that the girl was
wearing some Daisy Duke shorts and he's
like oh my
future girl I would pick it even more
and I would find like one of those Santa
Claus lingerie outfits for women what
are you trying to teach us nothing so
with all of their friends are [ __ ]
over at the house you come oh ho ho
that's ten times better than the parent
that doesn't know that they're not cool
anymore what's up homies girlfriend like
that mom was always trying to get in
like oh like she would try to have
conversations of like trying to
insinuate like you guys are you guys
[ __ ] any cute boys and we were all
like we don't talk to you about that yes
we never kicked that at her house but
she was always trying to be like I fit
in her clothes and she was like it was
[ __ ] those parents were so [ __ ]
crazy and stuff man it's so weird
what do you guys do it pop walk in later
time mr. Kim get the [ __ ] out of here
good like I've known a couple moms like
that too and then now that they're
grown-ups like they'll go clubbing or
like when they daughter hits 21 like
come on honey we're all gonna go Club it
up I know the club with their mom still
do we know this do we all know the same
person now talking about where they went
cried oh it sounds like G&R some [ __ ] no
party well do the other side mom come on
stop it
I do try stay home right no more I wants
to go clubbing yeah Gina is more of the
mom than Carolyn oh yeah that sounds
pretty fun Chloe with your mom I would
like parents that want a party with me
wait your own parents or just parents
cuz we're parents that party with you
know my mom nine I don't I don't want to
do anything you don't want to see her
get crazy or go wild no I think like
it's it's easy to fantasize about it
because you don't get that but then like
if that's all they're about and they're
embarrassing you it's like [ __ ] man why
you got to go to that man I don't want
to go to Las Vegas and then like I see
my mom like rolling and [ __ ] yeah it's
like awful
we went to this mansion party theme no
oh okay because he says I think he knows
about the Avalon like hell yes all that
[ __ ] like we would go to like house
clubs and stuff and we were still
friends and like I would go like in you
know denim and then like Edward trucks
cuz you actually danced at that time so
I was like there to just dance and then
you see like these like 40 or 50 year
old like a dream and not just she's like
Korean um like Chinese or giant whatever
like older Chinese parents and they
would wear like black Lopes inside the
club and they were just dance like
because they were rolling on E oh my god
I was like there's just all young people
and there always be these little groups
of like these old like Chinese people in
there I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
guys doing in here and they're [ __ ]
rolling their brains out yeah I remember
being little and thinking because I
would see my mom and like all her
sisters go out in club and stuff and I
remember thinking like oh I wish I could
go with you guys but then finally the
day before the wedding my mom and my two
aunts and my friends they took me out to
go to a bar and then we ended up somehow
stumbling in a strip club so I was in a
strip club with my mom my aunts and
friends yeah and France Oh what's a
French strip club like so then I'm there
and I'm like this is so weird like I
tapped into that little Tiffany and then
like brought her to see this and I'm
like this is crazy like I'm actually
partying up with my mom in my ass at a
strip club
it was so crazy if I see a stripper
putting his nuts on my mom's face I'd
[ __ ] vomit and there was only one
stripper then I would question my morals
cuz I'll be like damn she's hot and
she's giving me a boner but my mom's
there now I want to [ __ ] look at that
but what the hell is going on
[Laughter]
you supposed to be talking me
[Music]